In this video we shall discuss how to view issue details in Burp Street Enterprise Edition.
To start, select the Scans tab and select the Scan in Question. Next, navigate to the Issues
tab which will display all of the issues located during the scan. You can then select an issue
type and the path of the issue was found. This will display the advisory which will include
issue detail, background information, remediation steps, there will be a reference to our Web
Security Academy for that particular vulnerability, and the vulnerability classifications themselves.
We can also view the request and the response for the payload. We can also mark issues as false
positives or if we have the integration configured raise a ticket to remediate an issue. Thank you.
Thank you.